every day of your life make sure you
come straight home ordinary normal gets
like this there's only so long
what are you looking at what do I see
you in no one else can you know to
Monday where does it mundane someone
from the human world I'm not human than
what anything you wouldn't believe me if
I told you no no no you can't come home
you understand you don't come home
I've been killing demons for over a
third of my life
step
humans exist across the world in their
very different forms I don't understand
what I need this has to do with my mom
your mother was a shadow like him like
you there's a man inside your head
Larry you are the key to our survival
what is it about her she's different
she's gonna get us all killed
humanity from the very brink of
extinction
Jase thinks he needs to save the world
too many of them but you don't need to
encourage you to do it have a little
faith
you have an incredible gift we need you
the werewolves were here to save us
you